Oscar winners quote Karl Marx president
Trump torches his critics and the
Democratic presidential candidates B
clown themselves in Friday night's
debate we will examine the politics of
show business and the show biz of
politics also why the left can't meme
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show the
Oscars were last night you didn't watch
them me neither but we have the hi it's
we'll get to them and in the spirit of
the Oscars I wanted to take a moment
before we get too far down the road into
2020 just to acknowledge and commemorate
all those political campaigns that we
have already lost this year this is
going to be a positive campaign that
seeks to bring out the very best from
every single one of us III don't like
members of the press what the [ __ ] she
was looking back perhaps the worst
candidate ever to run from any party in
the history of this country the
president used taxpayer dollars to ask
the Ukrainians to help him cheat an
election my pronouns are she her and
hers
mine too you've gotta get up and stand
up and don't give up the fight I believe
in reproductive justice let's also not
forget someone in the trans community a
transfer male how did you feel you did
tonight I feel I did very good but then
I got off stage and
girlfriend you or so on now I appreciate
the comments of my colleagues this is
about the closest I'll probably ever
have in my life to an I am Spartacus
moment
[Music]
sorry to see them go I'm frankly
surprised that that Joe Biden hasn't
made the cut yet we will get into all of
the Democratic presidential race first I
want to cover the actual Oscars which
were last night which no one watched
myself included I simply watched the
highlights nobody actually watched the
whole telecast and that actually gets to
Hollywood's big problem the most radical
political moment of the night there were
really only three or four big moments
from this Oscars the most radical
political moment of the night came from
Julia rice shirt who won the Best
Documentary for American worker she
decided during her speech to quote Karl
Marx to the applause of the audience
working people have it harder and harder
these days and we believe that things
will get better when workers of the
world unite workers of the world unite
first of all that's not true right now
we have record low unemployment across
all sectors we have a record high
economy and we have wages rising for the
first time in ten years so workers are
not suffering relatively in this country
right now they're actually doing well
for the first time in a long time
workers of the world unite is Karl
Marx's call to arms from the Communist
Manifesto that is a direct quote of the
inventor of communism and the the point
I guess she's making is that all workers
will do better under communism but we
know that that isn't the case every
communist government on earth has been
absolute hell for workers it's been
absolute hell especially for workers
whether it's in the Soviet Union whether
it's in Cuba whether it's in China
whether it's anywhere in the world the
workers have not only been oppressed
they've very often been slaughtered on
mass but then the cherry on top is my
favorite part of this whole moment
American Factory was the first film
produced by Barack and Michelle Obama's
new production company
the production company's higher ground
productions so obviously they just give
this a word because Obama's attached to
it I think as part of it and because it
has this kind of underlying communist
message but I just want to point out
when conservatives would decry them the
radicalism and extremism of Barack Obama
the left and the mainstream media would
tell us oh you're crazy you're
hysterical you're not Obama's a moderate
it's no big deal his first movie to win
an Oscar in the acceptance speech they
quote Karl Marx they quote probably the
most famous line from Karl Marx so don't
tell me the guy is a moderate his
projects or moderate just ain't the case
so that was the most radical political
moment of the night the most bizarre
political moment of the night came from
Joaquin Phoenix who also wanted to get
in on the politics and he wanted to use
it to go after a very specific political
issue he wanted to protest milk we feel
entitled to artificially inseminate a
cow and when she gives birth we steal
her baby even though her cries of
anguish are unmistakable and then we
take her milk that's intended for a calf
and we put it in our coffee and our
cereal I did not see that one coming I
did not know that milk was going to be
the big new leftist hobbyhorse I will
point out what king Phoenix is an
environmentalist he does not simply want
to protect the environment because it's
good for human beings and we want to be
good stewards of the environment he
seems to have a much more radical view
of environmentalism the idea that the
natural environment sort of has rights
that animals have rights that we are
here to serve the natural environment
and so the idea that we would take a
cows little baby or kill a cows little
baby is so repugnant to him he takes it
even further the the fact that we would
drink a cow's milk is morally repugnant
to him this
is a guy who is on stage at the Oscars
where people are endorsing abortion it's
just I don't want to beat a dead horse
here at OU or beat a dead cow or drink
the dead cow's milk I just want to point
out the absolute incoherence of being an
environmentalist who cares about animal
rights of worrying about the little baby
calf of not eating veal of being so
afraid of causing harm to an animal that
you won't drink a glass of milk
but then endorsing killing a million
babies a year in the United States alone
doesn't make a whole lot of sense it's
it's a comes from a place of
sentimentality because we think of the
little cows face and we try not to think
of the baby's face but maybe we should
think of the baby's face and probably
that would cause those Hollywood people
to shut up for a little bit we will get
to my the lamest political moment of the
night which I think actually probably
was my favorite and then we will get to
Brad Pitt but first I've got to thank
our friends over at Ashford University
Ashford University's online bachelor's
and master's degree programs allow you
to learn at your own pace Ashford
University's six-week long courses allow
you to take one course at a time and
you're still considered a full time
student you now much I push education on
this show I think that part of the
reason why bad actors have totally
wrecked our culture is because they've
kept us very uneducated well look we
need to shake up the educational
establishment Ashford is doing just that
the SAT the GRE the GMAT other
standardized test scores are not
required for enrolling at Ashford
University Ashford University is fully
accredited by W ASC senior college in
University Commission there are a lot of
problems with American higher education
we talk all the time about how we've got
to change up this model the current
model is not working well one way to
change it up is to go check out Ashford
get on the road to earning your degree
in making your dream job a reality
enroll now by going to Ashford edu slash
Knowles Canada wles that's Ashford edu
slash Knowles Canada wles to start your
degree today Ashford edu / Knowles so
we've got communist
proclamations from the Oscar stage then
we've got an impassioned plea not to
drink milk and then we have the lamest
political moment of the night which came
from I am told Sigourney Weaver brie
Larson and gal gadot I did not recognize
any of these people
apparently they play superheroes in some
movie but that was the point they wanted
to make sure that their audience knew
when they got on stage that really
they're not the only superheroes that
really all women or superheroes sorry we
also wanted to stand here together and
say that all women are superheroes Wow
okay all right all women are superheroes
how about Betsy DeVos Betsy DeVos as a
woman is Betsy DeVos the Secretary of
Education is she a superhero because I
think she's just terrific
but the left is always telling me that
Betsy DeVos is Hitler so is she a
superhero actually speaking of Hitler
what about Ava Braun Hitler's mistress
is Eva Braun a superhero because Eva
Braun is a woman and I am told that all
women are superheroes so I guess by that
definition
Ava Braun is a superhero what kind of
psycho gets on a oscar stage and calls
Ava Braun a superhero the reality of
course is that women are not superheroes
women are women and men are men and this
kind of saccharine nonsense is I
how do people applaud for this stuff I
mean it's the same kind of saccharine
nonsense that has them applauding for
workers of the world unite these are
just completely empty platitudes
that have taken to their logical
conclusions have pretty bad implications
for society but you just hear women are
super what if a guy got up there say you
know men are superheroes men do some
cool stuff of course there would be no
applause for that but for some reason we
indulge in it's so condescending so
condescending to say to women oh yes
you're you're a superhero it's the sort
of thing you'd say to a three-year-old
where the super their three-year-old
comes out says I'm Superman
yes you are Johnny you are Superman
we're indulging these overgrown
actresses and don't
ostensibly adult actresses we're
indulging them like their three-year-old
children there's nothing particularly
feminist about that or particularly
respectful then you get to the dumbest
political moment of the night that came
from Brad Pitt thank you the Academy for
this honor of honors they told me I only
have 45 seconds up here which is 45
seconds more than the Senate gave John
Bolton this week I'm thinking maybe
Quentin doesn't move you about it in the
end the adults do the right thing what
what are the odds that Brad Pitt knows
who John Bolton is he might know that
John Bolton is that guy with the
mustache what are the odds that Brad
Pitt knows that John Bolton was the
national security adviser forget knows
what he worked on well he was national
security adviser what are the odds that
he knows that John Bolton was the UN
Ambassador what are they what are the
odds that he knows anything about what
he's talking about very low he says to
use 45 seconds more than John Bolton got
in the Senate huh what are the odds that
Brad Pitt knows that it was the
Democratic House not the Republican
Senate that decided not to call John
Bolton to testify the Democratic House
when they were calling 1718 witnesses
all to help the Democrats case not a
single one to help the Republicans case
they wanted to call John Bolton the
White House said no so they followed
normal procedure took it to the courts
and then the Democrats withdrew their
request is they just wanted to go along
and impeach the president get the vote
over with move on to the Senate because
they knew it was all Kabuki theater
because they knew that John Bolton
didn't have nothing because they know
they didn't have nothing on drum panned
they just wanted to get it over with so
that they could tell their rube base
that they had actually impeached the
president what are the odds of Brad Pitt
knows that Brad Pitt doesn't know that
cuz he's part of the roof base we will
get to what this means for Hollywood in
a second because I think Brad Pitt's
speech in particular it tells you a lot
about it first I want to talk about good
art I want to talk about paint your life
if you want to give a
truly meaningful gift you've got to try
paint your life calm actually give it a
gift to yourself so I think about this
all the time in my apartment in my
office and like having paintings on the
wall like having artwork on the wall
paint your life is an incredible way to
do this so you get a true painting done
by hand my paint your life is an oil
painting absolutely beautiful by a
world-class artist it's not some trick
it's not just made by a computer and you
think it's a painting it's a real
painting done by hand you upload a photo
of yourself or your family or your dog
or a favorite place that you like and
the artist will paint this they will
work with you every step of the way
until every detail is perfect so you'll
be getting different proofs and there's
no risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded I did
not believe that this would work I
didn't think you could get really high
quality or it this way so I order it for
my stepbrothers wedding it comes back
absolutely beautiful I'm working with
these guys again it makes a wonderful
Valentine's Day gift fellas coming up or
birthday or anniversary or just on a
Tuesday right now it's a limited time
offer you get 30% off your painting you
will not regret this go right now and
check it out it is an unbelievable
product 30% off free shipping to get
this offer text the word michael mi CH
AE l to 64,000 that's mi CH AE l to
64,000 mi CH AE l to 64,000 all right
the trouble with Brad Pitt speech trim
with all these speeches I like Brad Pitt
I thought he did a great job in once
upon a time in Hollywood I was hoping he
would win the Oscar for it he did a
really good job I did like watching him
perform that speech made me like him
less because it made me respect him less
it's not even I disagreed with what he
was saying he didn't say anything in
particular it was what children do when
children want to have a political
conversation with adults is they just
sort of insinuate things Jaya John
Bolton didn't speak okay do you know why
he didn't speak I a just bad that he
didn't speak yeah okay why would that be
bad it's the adults should do something
about it okay
do you know do you even know what you
think you're talking about
no now really cuz right cuz you're a
movie star we want you to be a movie
store we don't want you to insinuate
that you sort of understand kind of what
the political issues about this speech
makes us like and less not be even
because of the content or the political
content but because it just degrades him
my conclusion from all of this is they
need to stop televising the Oscars they
have to for the Oscars own sake for
Hollywood's own sake they have to stop
televised again the whole point of the
Oscars is to get us to like the movies
more but in reality the Oscars make
people hate the movies the movies
sometimes make us like the movies the
Oscars always make us like the movies
less these days without the Oscars of
the Oscars we're not televised the
movies and the movie stores would be
much much more popular so I think they
should keep having the Oscars I think it
should be like any other trade awards
show any other industry awards show they
go to some convention center and there
are no cameras whatsoever and they give
out awards to each other for who had the
best direction who had the best at
performance and then there aren't really
as quite as many popular political
considerations because they're not gonna
get blowback for hashtag Oscars to mail
hashtag Oscars do this
hashtag Oscars do that it's an actual
industry awards show where all the
artists vote on each other's work and
there's no cameras and there's no
showboating if they do that for enough
years they will remember what the point
of this awards show is which is to
celebrate movies and to bring the bro
best work up and to not run your mouth
about John Bolton performers used to
know this take a look at this is a clip
of Elvis Presley the king of rock and
roll in the 1970s right very heated
political moment you got all the
craziness of the late 1960s the early
70s eating of Vietnam and Elvis has
asked a political question here's his
answer mr. Presley on the subject of the
service what is your opinion of war
protesters and would you today refused
to be drafted
honey I just I just wanted to keep my
own personal views about that to myself
I'm just an entertainer and I I'd really
not say do you think other entertainers
should keep their views to themselves to
see even right.he they say hey mr.
Presley what are your political views he
was like I'm just an entertainer I don't
want to lose half my audience and I'm
obviously not qualified to talk about
politics I'm a guy who wears a jumpsuit
or does karate chops and sings beautiful
beautiful songs so I just don't spend my
time thinking about Vietnam I'd keep my
views to myself she goes oh yeah do you
think other people should keep their
views to themselves because I don't even
want to answer that note i whatever move
on ask me about jailhouse rock or
something performers used to know this
Dolly Parton still doesn't give her
views on politics right she's of that
old school that all kind of changed in
the 70s and it really was led in many
ways by the Oscars they got to go back
to it it's killing the Oscars it's
killing the movies and it's killing me
because I have to watch even part of
this award show and that's unfortunate
now there was a great show that took
place over the past few days that would
be the press trump press conference
celebrating his exoneration so President
Trump holds a press conference at the
White House right after his official
acquittal in the impeachment trial Trump
said this was not a press conference
this was a celebration now conservatives
are completely split on this all right
some loved that he spiked the football
some hated that he did take it too far
they said it was an unnecessary presser
it was an unnecessary escalation of
things I think both sides are completely
missing the point here to begin the
press conference started out great
this is really not a news conference
it's not a speech it's not anything it's
just we're sort of it's a celebration
because we have something that just
worked out I mean it worked out we went
through hell unfairly did nothing wrong
did nothing wrong I've done things wrong
in my life I will admit
not purposely but I've done things wrong
but this is what the end result is you
can take that home money maybe we will
frame it it's the only good headline
I've ever had in the Washington so it
starts out very funny even sort of
self-effacing right he says look I've
done a few things wrong okay I'm willing
to admit it a full-on narcissist can't
admit that he's ever done anything wrong
this is like I've done a few things
wrong okay all right maybe like I've
never gotten a good headline the
Washington Post it's funny it's
victorious its triumphant does great
then it got even better when president
from started going after his adversaries
like Mitt Romney and then you have some
that used religion as a crutch they
never used it before an article written
today never heard him use it before but
today you know it's one of those things
but you know two failed presidential
candidates so things can happen when you
fail so badly running for president but
Josh Charlie I want to thank you you
were right from the beginning man did I
make a good choice great he won't even
say Romney's a name right he just goes
yeah there's some people were a little
tough on us but they failed they failed
so badly so badly
hey all right I made a great choice and
it just moves on again it's great it's
got this balance it's got this sense of
humor he is spiking the football he's
giving you what you want he's pummeling
that principle is hack Mitt Romney but
he's still got this levity to it then he
took it slightly too far we'll get to
that in a second first I've got to thank
our friends over at light stream please
please please take care of your credit
card debt I've had too many friends and
family who have gotten in a very bad
position because they don't deal with
their credit card debt it is time to
consolidate your credit card debt into
just one payment at a lower fixed rate
so that you can start saving money and
that's very easy with a credit card
consolidation loan from light stream
rates are as low as five point nine five
percent APR with auto pay it's much
lower than the National
averages interest rates on credit cards
that can be over 20 percent APR you just
throwing money away get a loan from five
to $100,000 with absolutely no fees
here's one customers testimonial yeah he
goes quote I applied for this loan after
hearing an ad on the radio ever the
skeptic I decided to check it out anyway
I was amazed how easy the process was
and had the money in my bank account
within two days I would recommend this
company to everyone it's so important
and you could just be hemorrhaging money
right now unnecessarily don't do it just
for my listeners apply now to get a
special interest rate discount and save
even more the only way to get this
discount is go to light stream dot-com
slash Knowles Canada ula s Li gh T STR e
am calm slash Knowles kena wles
subject credit approval rate includes
0.50% auto pay discount terms and
conditions apply and offers a subject to
change without notice visit light stream
comm slash Knowles for more information
so it starts out well at this Trump
press conference gets even better when
he starts to hammer Romney then he takes
it slightly too far we've been going
through this now for over three years it
was evil it was corrupt it was dirty
cups
it was leakers and Liars we first went
through Russia Russia Russia it was all
Adam Schiff is a vicious horrible person
Nancy Pelosi is a horrible person but
now we have that gorgeous word I never
thought a word would sound so good it's
called total acquittal okay okay first
of all total acquittal is two words
alright you see that's Joy Behar playing
it on the view and then she gets that
dig in at the end there were two
conservative reactions to this two
distinct ones the first one says that
it's great it's hilarious they love it
they like that he says that naughty word
they like that he's getting really
personal then the other conservative
reaction is I hate it it's terribly
shouldn't do this why is he doing this
shut your mouth don't tweet don't talk
you're ruining it you're ruining
everything both gut both are wrong both
reactions are wrong I hate it when the
president swears in public I hate it
it's the only thing he does that I don't
like in his official capacity as
president you know a little bill or a
little law here and there but otherwise
I think he's doing an excellent job and
I hate it makes my skin crawl when he
swears in public I think it is degrading
okay I hate that he had to give this
press conference I wish he didn't have
to give this press conference I wish
that we were living in a time where the
president could have given that amazing
State of the Union address and then
walked off glorious into the sunset back
to the White House and just gotten down
to business and not had to give this
press conference that was a little
meaner and a little more reality being a
little tougher we don't live in that
time we live in a very very corrupt time
in a degraded time and President Trump
had to give this press conference and
what's even worse he had to take it too
far he had to because he had to get all
these liberals like Joy Behar on the
view to tell their audience that he was
acquitted if Trump just went out there
if first of all if you just left it at
the State of the Union we wouldn't hurt
a thing about it and a lot of the
country which isn't paying very close
attention to politics would probably not
even know that he got acquitted they
would just hear he was impeached he was
impeached right that's all the Democrats
are saying so if he just left it in the
State of the Union wouldn't do him any
good there'd be a lot of misinformation
out there now if he had given this press
conference but it just said look I won I
was acquitted no big deal Romney's a
jerk we're moving on even if he had just
done that wouldn't have worked there
would have been nothing about that clip
that the left would have had to play
it's because he took it too far and did
things that I hate like swear in public
and get really really nasty and personal
and did you hear what he said he goes
that one word that I love that one word
total acquittal now that's not one word
did president Trump know that that's not
one word I suspect he did I suspect the
billionaire who's been a real estate
developer genius who is married to the
supermodel who became president on his
first try and who was the king of
reality TV I suspect he knows that total
acquittal is more than one word than
it's two words okay
but by saying that and giving his
opponents an opening to attack him the
clip gets played when you say this is BS
the clip gets played and when the clip
gets played on the view what happens Joy
Behar says total acquittal it's not
total acquittal what if it were total
acquittals two words they play his words
and that reaches a whole lot of people a
lot more people than those of us who
were paying a lot of attention it's
frustrating but this is a tactic and
it's by the way I'm this is not some
conspiracy like I'm reading 4d chess
into Trump he has done this since the
early 80s he has done is he's ginned up
a sort of negative headline that he then
rides to get his message out he did it
in the New York tabloids he did it on
network television and he's doing it now
in the political press as president all
right this is the most consistent tactic
he's used in his whole career and I wish
we didn't have to use it but we do and
so you got to defend these kind of press
conferences you have to it's it's the
only coherent way to say well you could
say I'd love what Trump does but I hate
how he does it okay well how else you
gonna do it yet
Mitt Romney Pierre de lecto over there
guess what he doesn't win and even if he
did when he'd probably be spineless
about it comes with the territory it's
an unfortunate reality but politics is
about reality okay we've got a lot to
get to we got to get to that democratic
debate we've got there's a whole lot
more to get to first it feels like we're
already halfway through 2020 we actually
haven't even gotten started the
elections heating up we know you need to
stay up to date so we're giving you 20%
off all memberships that is 20% off when
using promo code DW 2020
what do members get articles ad free
access to our live broadcasts and show
library the full three hours of the ben
shapiro show select bonus content the
mailbag and now election inside op-eds
from ben shapiro plus our new all access
to your gets you into live online Q&A
discussions with me Ben Drew Matt Walsh
plus our sites writers even special
guests you ask we answer the leftist
ears temblor fills right up download The
Daily wire app a member exclusive so you
can get push notifications straight to
your phone that's promo code DW 20/20
for 20% off join today
and stay informed on all things 2020
dailyrx.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
the democratic debate did you even know
there was a democratic debate you
probably didn't know the Oscars were
last night you probably did see that
from press conference and I'm certain
you didn't watch the democratic debate
on Friday night but I did because I'm a
masochist so this debate goes on this is
right after the debacle in Iowa they're
heading into New Hampshire we still
don't know who the winner is by the way
we did again they're saying now it's
Budaj edge it's pretty dodgy we don't
know for sure who the winner is
this was a devastating debate for
Democrats and the Democrats knew it
would be a devastating debate and that's
why they buried it on a Friday night
when even fewer people than usual would
be watching it was devastating for a few
reasons the most most important one is
it exposed how radical all of the
Democrats are Bernie Sanders remains the
Democratic frontrunner he very likely
won Iowa even though officially they're
probably gonna give it to boo to judge
but it looks probably like he got more
votes he's at the top of all the polls
in New Hampshire he's doing well
everywhere
the Democratic frontrunner denounced the
entire country from top to bottom quote
as hopelessly racist here's Bernie have
a racist society from top to bottom
impacting health care housing criminal
justice education you name it and
clearly this is an issue that must be
dealt with but in terms of criminal
justice what we have got to do is
understand the system is broken is
racist we invest in our young people in
jobs and education not more jails and
incarceration we end the war on drugs
which has disproportionately impacted
african-americans Latinos and Native
Americans we end private prisons and
detention centers in America so what's
interesting about Bernie and all of the
Democrats when they talk about racial
issues is they always immediately go to
drugs and crime it says no when you ask
them about any kind of racial issues
that what are you gonna do for the black
community what are you gonna do for the
Latino community they say yeah we're
gonna give them lighter sentences for
all their crimes and we're
to give him more drugs to take a look
that's that that actually is racist from
top to bottom if the first thing you
think of when you think of black people
is drugs in crime like Bernie Sanders
that's not a great look he still said
even though he exhibited this kind of
bigotry himself he said that the whole
country is racist top to bottom
you can't chalk that kind of thing up
just to one crazy socialist okay you
could you could say this one a lot of
people's trying to say Bernie is at the
top of the heap sure he might be the
front-runner but he doesn't represent
the mainstream of the Democratic Party
except he does what this debate showed
us in particular was that Bernie Sanders
has remade the Democratic Party in his
own image one of the moderators asked
all of the candidates they said do any
of you feel uncomfortable with
nominating an open socialist for
president not a single one raised their
hand anyone else on the stage concerned
about having a Democratic Socialist at
the top of the Democratic ticket
I'm not senator klobuchar okay and then
so you see at the very end so no one
raises their hand then at the end a me
kind of puts your hand up and puts it
back down so it's a little unclear is
she uncomfortable with being a socialist
or is she just trying to answer the
question then Bernie I'm pretty raised
as the saying goes I'm not I'm not
uncomfortable with that at all because
bernie is is the open socialist all of
them every single one of them just gave
their assent to socialism and Joe Biden
was saying a little while ago he said
look if we nominate Bernie or this was
at least attributed to Biden and people
around him if we nominate Bernie then
the demo and the next and we don't want
that socialist label well then you
probably should have objected when you
were asked that question because as of
now every single major Democratic
candidate for president has just said
that they're fine with a socialist being
their nominee they're fine being
represented by a socialist then you you
see how this trickles down the whole
campaign we knew that Bernie was a
socialist we knew Elizabeth Warren was
going to become a radical she became a
radical a few months ago then she
released that crazy health care plan
fifty two trillion dollar health care
plan wealth tax just confiscating wealth
from people and her campaign started to
sink but even Joe Biden old sleepy Joe
been around for a hundred years Joe
Biden himself has become a radical used
to be relatively moderate especially on
the issue of abortion now Joe Biden is
all the way in even on an issue as
personal and controversial as abortion
mr. vice president I am aware of what
you said which is why I'm asking would
you do it differently now would there be
a litmus test on abortion yes look
here's the deal
lipid testing abortion relates to the
fundamental value in the Constitution a
woman does have a right to choose I
would in fact if they rule it to be
unconstitutional I will send to the
United States Congress and it will pass
I believe a
bill that that that excuse me legislates
Rovi way to dodge adjusted by Casey oh
man he just went the whole way I mean he
used to say people can have difference
of opinion on abortion I don't support
taxpayer funding of abortion then a few
months ago he started to support tax
very funding of abortion now he's saying
it would be a litmus test for a judge if
you don't support abortion you're out
you're out of the running we're not
allowed to have litmus tests but
apparently the left is allowed to have
litmus tests and then the worst so
Bernie we always knew as a wacko warned
is collapsing biden is now a radical and
can barely form nglish sentence then you
get to the worst Canada my least
favorite in the entire race Pete boo to
judge Pete he is the worst of all I know
he seems like kind of a nice guy I know
you think oh that guy he couldn't have
cheated and stolen Iowa oh that guy he
couldn't be a radical oh that guy he is
the single worst candidate and he didn't
do very well in this debate especially
when he was asked about racial issues he
was asked why black people in the town
he's the mayor of South Bend Indiana why
they were getting incarcerated and
arrested at a higher rate than than
white people and he totally flubbed the
answer how do you explain the increase
in black arrests in South Bend under
your leadership for marijuana possession
and again the overall rate was lower
the year before you were in office it
was lower once you became in office in
2012 that number went up in 2018 the
last number a year that we have record
for that number was still up drag him
that's right go get him you know I don't
even know that moderator is but good job
good job nailing him on it because Pete
Buddha judge more than any other
candidate is duplicitous two-faced
insincere will lie directly to your face
he's better at it than Joe Biden even
probably Joe Biden's lost a little bit
with age Bernie Sanders doesn't really
lie to your face he's actually pretty
honest with you and Elizabeth Warren is
incompetent at it but Pete Buddha judge
will lie to your foot he will relieve
himself on your leg and tell you that it
is raining and she was having none of it
said look the arrest rate went down
while I was mayor saying no it didn't we
have the numbers the numbers don't lie
you lie people to judge but the numbers
don't so
she pushes him on it let's hear her push
him on it again and then his answer
could not have been worse his answer was
worse than than Bernie who just comes at
a Scalia's and he just starts talking
about crime Pete Buddha judges answer
was even more to the point once you
became in office in 2012 that number
went up in 2018 the last number a year
that we have a record for that number
was still up yeah and one of the
strategies that our community adopted
was to target when there were cases
where there was gun violence and gang
violence which was slaughtering so many
in our community burying teenagers
disproportionately black teenagers we
adopted a strategy that said that drug
enforcement would be targeted in cases
where there was a connection to the most
violent group or gang connected to a
murder these things are all connected
but that's the point
these things are all connected that's
the this was a bad this was one of those
moments where poopit at Buddha judge
tells you what he really feels because
he does feel that these things were all
connected did you listen to the logical
line in his answer they say okay why
were black people arrested at a higher
rate for drugs in your under your
mayorship and he said no they weren't
and she said no actually they were we
have the numbers they were
rested in higher numbers at a higher
rate when you were mayor why is that and
he said well we prioritized arresting
violent people so Pete Buddha judges
answer as to why more black people were
arrested for the same crime when he was
mayor is because the black people are
just more violent and that's his answer
this is a sort of answer where if you if
you put him behind a veil right if you
were just listening to this on the radio
and you kind of mixed up the voices a
little bit that could have been an
answer given by one of these white
racialist guys now I'm not accusing
people to judge of being a white
racialist I'm accusing the Democrats of
hypocrisy on racial issues because these
answers if these answers were given by a
Republican or a conservative this would
be top of the news for weeks and weeks
and weeks but the Democrats have no
answer on racial issues they have no
account for their own history on racial
issues and they don't want the public to
see these candidates it's just like the
Oscars the more you see the movie stars
the more the movie stars come into your
own living room
the less you like them and it's the the
more these candidates talk the less you
like them that's why they're burying
this debate on Friday nights Buddha
judge did not do terribly well at this
debate the worst thing look Buddha judge
is rising to the top now because he's
trying to get the moderate Lane from Joe
Biden so there's a world in which this
thing comes down to Bernie Sanders and
Pete boo to judge Pete Budaj edge is
nothing he only speaks in platitudes
when he's not accidentally making these
racial comments here's just an example
this is the typical Budaj edge answer on
virtually any topic from the same debate
we cannot solve the problems before us
by looking back we have to be ready to
turn the page and change our politics
before it's too late and I'm seeing
everywhere I go not just fellow
Democrats but a striking number of
independents and what I like to call
future former Republicans ready to join
in that historic American majority to
turn the page what did
he just say can you try now just write
get a pen and paper write down in one
sentence what he actually said that
means anything he said we can't go
forward if we are going back we have to
come together and we need people who
disagreed with us to agree with us and
we need to do those things together you
know and you know it's like the universe
man it's sort of like we're all like
we're all one you know it doesn't he
said nothing he just uses words and he
says enough of them together that it
makes it seem like he's saying something
and that's the Democratic field in a
nutshell they're just saying nothing
nothing that people want to hear at
least one candidate who's jumping up the
polls was not there that candidate is
Mike Bloomberg he bought his way into
the next debate but he wasn't able to
buy his way into this debate and so he
sent the whole debate sending out
terrible memes and I want to show you
it's a tale of two means to show you
what we often hear that the left can't
meme the left doesn't know how to use
newfangled Internet speak to convey the
ideas that they want to convey the right
happens to be very good it means most of
the memes on the Internet come from the
right why is that Mike Bloomberg shows
us so during this debate he's not
invited he decide he sends that this
meme I will I will narrate it it's a
meme of of Donald trying and he says he
said this is Donald Trump's recent
speech and in the end of meme he says
lie lie lie unfair lie lion in the meme
is a little gingerbread cookie
gingerbread man who's catching on fire
and smoking and it's just kind of
jumping around the screen and it's a
little gingerbread man and it doesn't
make any sense
it's completely random and it's getting
a lot of scorn and mockery on the
internet by people who can mean okay
that's the bloomberg meme compare that
to the Trump meme that he just put out
Trump meme this is put out by the White
House social media director and then
Trump retweeted and said select all the
squares with the president like those
little security measures that you get
when you go on different websites right
you have to pick all the squares with
the crosswalk or with the traffic light
and it's a photo of
Ultra I'm standing next to Mitt Romney
it's you select all the squares with
Trump in it and then obviously you don't
select the squares with Romney in it
that's a funny meet got got decent play
it's like why is it funny because it
means something it it's clever it's a
little mean it's not direct it's not
just right out there telling you exactly
what it means
it's it's depicting what it means you it
has some art to it you have to use your
mind a little bit but the message is
clear once you appreciate what what the
work is telling you why why can't the
left meme it's because of what Mike
Bloomberg thinks Bloomberg's team thinks
that memes are just random things you
just throw a bunch of random stuff
together and then at the end of all that
random stuff that's funny and that's
gonna make you look cool and hip or
something that's not what a meme does
the the definition of a meme is not it's
a lack of meaning it's that it is full
of meaning right the reason that the
left thinks it's all this random
nonsense is because the left doesn't get
what we're saying well there are studies
to back this up John Hyde did a study a
number of years ago showed that the
right understands the left pretty well
but the left doesn't understand the
right they don't know what we think they
don't know how we view the world and so
to them when we convey our worldview in
these kind of silly images online it
just looks like random nonsense to them
but it's not random nonsense it's
actually conveying something that they
simply can't understand so then they try
to recreate that by creating random
nonsense and we mock them because that's
not me
that is there's much more to say on this
topic but in a nutshell that's why the
left cannot mean there is much much more
to get to but we are simply out of time
so we can chew on that we can ponder
that we can we can think of all these
memes tonight maybe send them out tweet
them at me I'm very bored all day so
please send me memes then we will get to
so much more tomorrow there's a OC is
out with something
it explains another big flaw of the left
but you'll just have to wait until then
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knoll show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation